so please don't dash off to lunch it'll
be great so I'm very happy
welcome to club Cornell Tech will be
talking with us about what our ml models
providing utility is another one of
these folks who every time I hear you
speak I feel like there's a not so good
surprise you guys got yourselves a good
news fatale and bad news Vitale right
okay um all right so thanks for having
me here
so today so this is going to be a very
high-level talk no technical details in
it and there is a reason for that
they're actually like some some
technical details that I'm happy to kind
of share you know the hallways and so on
but what I really want to do is describe
a problem which is I feel like I kind of
stumbled on this problem and and by
problem I don't mean like problem as
like problematic as like there is
something interesting going on there is
a research problem in all of this and
I'm just trying to get a handle on this
so this is going to be kind of a very
high-level attempt to describe what this
thing gets and so the title of this talk
is what are a male models hiding and I
know in the program it was described as
unwanted learning but but that's exactly
what I'm gonna be talking about unwanted
learning for lack of a better name
actually if anybody has a better name
for what I'm describing like tell me at
the end of my talk all right so so
alright here we go
so I I don't know much about machine
learning unfortunately but but in my
kind of very imperfect understanding of
it it works something like this so you
take a data set
and you put it for some
you know fancy thing you know like
tensorflow
PI torch or what have you and you know
run on GPUs and whatnot and outcome
models and you use these models for
something like prediction or analysis of
something or other and so on okay that's
about all I know about machine learning
but one thing I noticed is that
typically when people use this like how
do they know that the thing is actually
working and working as intended so the
question that they typically ask when
they do this what does what do you think
is the question that ml people ask when
they go through this process of taking a
data set and building a model on it so
what does the main thing they seem to
care about this accuracy oh no I mean
like look at your colleagues you know
from Google brain I mean is that's what
they really ask I mean can I sell it
they have people in the next building to
do the selling for them right
no they ask exactly they ask like tasks
like guest accuracy which is another way
of saying did the model actually learn
the tasks that I gave okay so as far as
I can tell that's what they care about
and that is indeed captured by test
accuracy meaning that they train a model
for a particular task then they take a
bunch of data that they didn't use your
own training give it to the model the
model produces some results and they
measure if the results are good and
that's test accuracy and that's kind of
how the whole thing works so so far so
good what I'm going to try to argue over
the next half hour or so is that this
question about test accuracy and did the
model learn its task well important as
it maybe doesn't cover everything you
might want to know about the model and
it certainly doesn't cover everything
you might want to know if you care about
things like security and privacy and
integrity
and all these things that there is a lot
that could be happening in a model both
good and bad that is not actually
captured at all by test accuracy and is
not even captured by this kind of high
level question of did the model learn
the task I gave it did it learn it well
so the first inkling that there is
something more going on and in modern
machine learning then then is there is
that good news
Natali okay so so all right the first
thing link that there is more going on
than then is captured by this notion of
test accuracy is something that you guys
all know about that you might have
actually heard me talk about this
because I've been talking about this for
the past couple of years a lot and this
is this idea of leakage from the output
of the model so this is the kind of
thing that is not gonna for most of you
is old news it's the idea that if you
look at what the model is producing so
in this case let's say it's a simple
classification model so it produces some
distribution over classes with
associated probabilities that it turns
out that very often these models pray
they behave differently that as they
produce differently shaped distributions
on training and non training inputs so
that's kind of a very basic thing you
know that as you well know is going to
enable membership inference but one
thing that I wanna one point that I want
to make about this is that this
difference is not really captured by
test accuracy at all because test
accuracy typically is about the like
list prediction so the model could be
leaking all kinds of information in this
case it's information about membership
and the training except through what
it's outputting kind of outside its
lightless prediction
and that does more effect test accuracy
at all and test occurs it could remain
high and nevertheless there could be all
sorts of signal and output of the model
that leaked information so this thing is
could be actually these differences
could be exploited you can actually
train an adversarial model to tell the
difference which enables black box
membership inference so I'm not gonna
talk much about it since I already
talked a lot about this but it kind of
enables kind of these things like you
know you can tell if some you know
certain images are on the phone you can
Hale certain places or in a location
data SAP it also kind of provides nice
and traductor and material for
differential privacy papers so all the
good stuff but once you realize that
this is going on you get to start asking
questions so the first question that
comes to mind is that if this leakage if
this just goes I mean all I'm doing so
far is just looking at the output of the
model and they see that even if test
accuracy is the same it could still be
leaking information through its outputs
outside the most likely prediction but
but that's got a black box all I'm
seeing is the output of the model so the
next question to ask is how about I try
to look inside the model and see what
it's learning and by the way sorry just
just to make a bit point this question
does model leakage training data through
its output and a black box fashion this
this the answer to that question is
actually not captured by any of this so
that's kind of question number one but
no let's look inside the model and this
is where kinda the interesting part
starts for me and this is something that
I've been and obsessing a little bit
over the past year or so ever since we
first not as this that if you try to
look inside the model and try to kind of
understand what did the model actually
learn when you apply it when you applied
it to your training data we discovered
kind of all sorts of interesting things
so this is whatever it is I mean it's
kind of like a visual or it doesn't what
I'm trying to say it's like doesn't
matter what the task here is it's a
representation of the features that the
model
learned when you applied it to the
training data for a particular task and
it turns out that a bunch of these
features are actually features necessary
for the task that you gave it so so you
told that like in this particular case
the task is to you know think of it as
separating points by color where color
corresponds to a particular class and
you can see that the model has learned
it pretty well that as it separates this
features pretty well but the amazing
thing that was a revelation to me is
that in addition to discovering the
features that it clearly needs to
perform the task you gave it it also
discovered a whole bunch of other
features including features that leak
information that are like I have to pick
my adjective careful here it's not that
they're unnecessary because in some kind
of roundabout way they might be
necessary but they're certainly
uncorrelated with the task that you gave
ok so kind of just to give you kind of
an intuitive example for the kind of
things I'm talking about so it turns out
that I can train a model on a bunch of
facial images to recognize the race of
the person and it turns out that this
model also learns if the person wears
glasses or not ok even if wearing
glasses is uncorrelated statistic layer
with the person's race nevertheless the
model in the process of learning for a
particular task it discovers all this
other in this case facial features such
as wearing glasses that actually can
also tell if the person is happy or sad
so it discovers like a bunch of stuff
internally that is again I have to be
careful here not quite unrelated but
certainly statistically uncorrelated
with the task queue game so and this is
this is important because what this
tells me is that when you apply a model
to a data set and that's kind of the
main point that I'm trying to make today
when you apply sorry when you train a
model for a particular task on a data
set
it's gonna learn things and it's gonna
learn way more than just the task you
gave it and if all you're looking at is
did it learn the task you give it will
you're not actually like asking or
discovering what else the model has
learned beyond this it actually has
implications for privacy for example
another thing that we discovered that we
can trick train a model for a generic
task like recognizing gender recognizing
grace recognizing if somebody's happy or
sad and yet the model internally learns
representations that correspond to
individual identities so it actually
learns to recognize individual people
and the data set if there aren't enough
representatives there so here we have a
model that is trained for an ostensibly
a kind of very generic tasks like
sentiment detection but internally it
has the functionality of a facial
recognition model that actually
recognize individual people which
actually has implications for privacy it
also I feel has implications for
regulation of various kinds so and this
would be demonstrated very concretely
using transfer learning techniques so we
have this experiments that basically
show that you can take a model that was
used originally to like infer gender of
the face and you can derive a model that
actually infers the race of someone from
that model or the model is used in for
emotion and you can actually turn that
into facial recognition models and this
is not just for image detection at all
so the same effects we observe in NLP
models so for example you can take a
model for inferring sentiment of text
and you can use its internal
representations to create a model that
infers Watership no you don't need the
training gauge so imagine like the
training data is gone all you have is
the model trained for this task and then
I turn it into a model for this basket
a little bit so-so but not enough to
train a good model so I take a little
bit of training data for the new task I
can train a really crappy model on that
but that data plus the old model gives
me a good model for the new task now at
this point I have to kind of be very
careful about what I say because when we
first discovered this I was all like you
know canape myself with excitement and
kind of telling everybody about this and
like a Melfi like yeah you know like
everybody knows this right actually you
know I feel like whatever research I do
it's like people's reaction as everybody
knows this so yeah well that's you know
not a happy thought but but here is what
they mean by everybody knows that it is
true that that like if you look at a
male literature and like this design you
know not people like me like there's a
professional ml people so like you know
train imagenet models and kind of become
rich and famous off of that like they
don't know that there is like that
models discover things that are in some
sense more than you more than you ask
them to discover so like you can take a
model train for imagenet and for those
of you who don't know what it is this is
kind of a very rich kind an image
analysis image classification task and
you can use that model using very
similar transfer learning techniques to
perform all other kinds of image
classification tasks but that is not
quite what I'm talking about here
because of course if you train for image
net and training for image net meaning
training a model that can recognize like
thousands of different objects on the
image and like classify scenes in a very
refined way I mean it's not surprising
that you can use that model to solve
other image recognition tasks because in
some sense this is like learning in
general like computer vision like
learning image net is almost like you
know get a human level perception of
what's in the images another effect that
people have observed is that if you
trained for a coarse-grain task it
actually learns to recognize finer
grained versions of this task like for
example if you teach a model to
recognize
monkeys it doesn't just learn to
recognize monkeys it learns to tell like
I don't know like chimpanzees from like
macaques or something but again this is
like finer-grained version of the same
task the fact I'm observing here is
different
it's unlearning for a very simple task
I'm not training imagenet models I don't
have enough GPUs in my lab to do that
I'm learning like these are binary
classifiers like male or female this is
a very simple task and yet the
representations that the model is
learning turn out to be sufficient to
perform uncorrelated tasks other tasks
that are actually not a finer grained
version of the task I trained for I
trained for one task and then I can use
the model to train for an uncorrelated
task so that's the surprising thing here
is that Jana I'm not trying to solve the
general vision problem I'm using this
model to train for very simple things
and yet in spite of that inside of them
they end up discovering this very rich
representations and they extract generic
features that are actually useful for
all sorts of other things it's as if
like no matter like like for this tasks
like kind of no matter how I train the
only way to be training successfully is
to actually discover and the general
features that are useful for all sorts
of images the fact that the second test
is uncorrelated with the first test to
suggest that you shouldn't be learning
those features so it's like chimpanzees
and macaques look very different than
the features that are relevant to
recognizing chimpanzees and the features
recognized relevant for recognized
macaques might be very different so
recognizing monkeys or primates would
naturally give me a way to recognize
chimpanzees did distinguish chimpanzees
hmmm yeah maybe that's maybe that's
what's going
Dickinson and welder Iverson have very
different types of writing so sad okay
so there are two questions under what
you asked why this matters and why this
is surprising there's a different
questions right it sounded like you're
suggesting it's surprising and pushing
back on it's surprising to me and so far
I have not been able to find like any
evidence in the anywhere that this has
been observed that learning for a simple
task results in the discovery of generic
features that are useful for all kinds
of other tasks I haven't seen this but I
guess it's not surprising so yeah it's
not a simple task okay I think maybe if
you're saying that if inferring race is
a simple task because you've defined it
as looking at the gradient and people's
skin but we know when we're looking for
quote-unquote race which is a social
construct that the models are learning
lots of different things that are more
subtle than that and and that the
identification of race differs in
relation to gender right and so like I
think just to push on that okay good so
let me try to answer all of this kind of
in in one ramp so so that's why I have
to be careful by saying things like I
used to say things like unrelated and
then people pulled back and exactly the
way you are now so I you know
uncorrelated just means that in the data
set like if you look at label
the image for race and label for gender
there is no statistical correlation
between these labels that's all it means
it's a it's a pure like statistical
statement as that like you know half a
label does man half a label this women
and that's all that's all it is okay so
you can so it's not a statement about
like constructing identity I'm not
making a social science statement at all
it's just a pure mathematical statement
about the distribution of labels and the
data set okay but but it is really but
but but here is what like I feel is
really going on and this is to answer
the question about you know why do I say
it's a simple task so that's the point
I'm trying to make is that apparently it
is not a simple task that in the process
of learning for this binary classifier
the only way to learn it is to discover
to sort of perform full-on facial
analysis and to extract the relevant
features that now enable the model to do
not just the task you trained it for but
all sorts of other tasks and I do know
this because there are techniques that
come from bison from kind of biased
literature can you know Farrah Mel
community for censoring representations
okay censoring representations means
that you artificially sort of during
training try to prevent the model from
making decisions based on race for
example based on gender and based on
whatever prohibited attribute and these
techniques could be used to try to
suppress the model and prevent it from
learning things you don't want it to
learn and what do I observe empirically
that if you try to prevent the model
from learning one of these things it's
not going to learn others so the only
way to prevent it from learning these
concepts is to prevent it from kind of
learning performing like facial analysis
features or text analysis and so on and
in that case it fails at all tasks so
the point that I'm trying to make which
I mean to me is surprising that may mean
again it's not surprising to people who
actually know about this is that this
properties that you might want to learn
for the
in bundles okay as in like you either
learn all of them or you learn none of
them
okay I'm kinda simplifying it a little
bit because I mean there are certain
trade ups there but that's kinda
intuitively what's happening is that
either you kinda in case of image
analysis perform full analysis of like
faces and then you learn everything
there is to know about the face or you
learn none of this that there is no such
thing as a model that lets say learns if
people are happy or sad or if the face
is labeled as male or female without
learning all the other things like race
and if the person wears glasses and and
stuff like this including given facial
identities potentially so that's that's
the point I'm trying to make okay same
people but it's going to be harder to do
with different people I mean it but in
this case it's same people now here is
like here's I'm really gonna go out of
my kind of comfort zone and talk about
like regulation and whatnot but I will
okay so there is this thing called GDP
are out and Europe somewhere now and I
counted using grep it mentions the work
purpose 261 times it says that when you
do processing of data the purpose you
know for multiple purposes consent
should be given for all of them of
course these days data is going to be
used for Marshall learning that's what
people do with data these days and look
at this whole picture like what exactly
is the purpose like if you train a model
for a particular task but in the process
of training it for that task you are
whether you want it or not actually
training it for hundreds of other
possible tasks
it could be usable for those other tasks
what are the what is really the purpose
of the model so I feel this is going to
be a challenge for people who are
responsible for like disclosing purposes
to users and obtaining consent from them
explaining to users that look I got this
model and that trainer so I'm only gonna
use it for purpose eh
oh and by the way that very same model
could be used for all sorts of other
purposes and maybe it is in some sense
being used for those other purposes
because maybe in the process of like
doing this like neutral things that I
gave you actually happens to be
recognizing your face and recognizing
all kinds of your attributes that I
don't know you might or might not be
comfortable with so I don't know how all
of this is going to work with purpose I
mean this is not kind of my problem this
is somebody else's butt but I just want
to mention this because I feel that this
idea that you can take a model trained
for one task and because it has
implicitly learned all manner of other
things you can repurpose it very easily
for all sorts of other tasks even if the
data is no longer available of the data
has been erased
this is going to be a challenge all
right I mean this kind of you know
repurposing that you described here
doesn't seem to mean maybe it's not I I
just feel that it's very hard to tell
like I don't even know how to define a
purpose of an m/l model because the same
mm-hmm yes
this isn't a problem that is unique when
when we think about describing the
purpose the purpose is like Merida socio
technical level has the organization
using the technology it's not described
every purpose that the technology could
be used for alright so I agree with you
that there may be some interesting
things here but most technology is kind
of has multiple purposes and so the way
in which we think about no it's not
about like here is important difference
I'm not saying what this models are
capable of doing I'm talking about what
they're doing I mean there are actually
learning things so it's not about
potential users of this yes we don't say
that you have to limit what you're
building to only perform one possible
function and it prevents you from doing
anything else
the typical level we're saying whatever
it is that you use the day to build when
you're actually making decisions you can
only use it for this particular so yeah
I mean this is the thing that comes up
all the time so and this is kind of
where there is this disconnect between
bias and privacy comes comes into the
picture so to speak typically when
people do censoring of models for bias
they only care about the last layer of
the model as long as the decisions
you're producing have the right
statistical property like no disparate
impact or whatever I don't know certain
notions out there apparently you're good
okay however I feel like like what these
models are doing like like maybe the
decision has no bias but I don't know
how comfortable people are gonna be is
like you know what I'm gonna follow
inside the model different decision
paths I'm gonna make decisions one way
for white people and the different way
for black people and then actually my
decision my final decision is
independent or
turns out to have the right statistical
property but inside the model I'm doing
different things for different races is
that okay or not I'm not the right
person to answer that question but I do
suspect that if it turns out to be the
case lots of people are not gonna be
cool with that that's all I'm saying and
in some sense with these models are
doing is some of that as in they
actually do perform different so you
don't think sometimes the only way to
meet some measures of fairness is
actually to consider yes how models use
information about race gender age all of
these things maybe super important and I
think married discussion but the
question about whether or not they're
viewed as good or bad is a separate
question but I'm looking how they're
used can be really important at the very
least it seems like the you know there
there is a consciousness that like if
you are intentionally using features
like you know race or something in some
decision you should actually know you're
doing that I mean requirement to
understand like the process that's
that's going on and with these these
complicated models that are just
represented as a list of weights it's
not obvious that you that that's easy
right and it's not just about the output
that your reasoning
okay if it's not just about the output
then I would argue technically that for
many of these models there is no way of
eliminating race there is no way of
eliminating gender from their inner
workings because in the process of
arriving at their decisions they will
consider them because if you prevent
them from considering they're no longer
learn sorry I didn't like I didn't want
to get kind of I put this out there to
kind of establish a connection I'm not
trying to say like good or bad this is
not my area of expertise the only point
I'm trying to make is that when you
train a model for any one of these tasks
it ends up learning all of them
effectively that's that's the technical
point that I'm making how to feed it
into this picture of like regulation and
ethics and so on you guys are much
better equipped than me yeah not every
single task but but for certain I don't
know how to quantify over all possible
tasks but but we have these groups of
objective functions that if we like for
example if we try to censor for race it
no longer learns gender or in no longer
learns if people wear glasses those
types of things
sorry this is not with transfer learning
and just saying I'm like I'm gonna take
a model trained as a gender classifier
okay I'm gonna look at its
representation that's clear that it's
representations liek race I'm gonna
apply censoring techniques to prevent
their presentations from leaking race
the accuracy of gender classifier goes
down almost to random guessing that's it
that's the point I'm making there is no
transfer learning there it's just trying
to like regularize representation so
that they don't leak race prevents them
from being discriminative on gender
that's all
it doesn't say that there isn't way
although I feel that there isn't I feel
like for precisely the reason that like
good news Vitale said which is these
seemingly simple tasks are actually
complex that may be to actually learn
you know race or gender assigned
correctly you actually need to extract
like low-level features assemble them
into facial features and perform full-on
face analysis which will actually enable
facial recognition and there is just no
other way of accurately recognizing race
or gender like it would be very nice if
they were a simple way of doing it that
doesn't like pull in all this other crap
but there so far there doesn't seem to
be that's a beautiful thing so so that
is like what we thought and like the
mortals trained like like I should have
mentioned this is that even if you have
certain properties motor presenter than
the data set at all the model still
learns to recognize them which goes to
this point of like it's actually
extracting low-level facial features
okay an example sure you can train a
model to tell like Caucasian and
african-american faces apart that model
turns out to be capable of recognizing
Asian faces even though Asian faces are
not represented in the training dataset
it shouldn't be surprising at all now
your again okay first your tell them
that there is nothing surprising here
and then you're all like sitting here
huh what but if the model is extracting
low-level features visible level
features are discriminative not just for
the things represented on the training
data set their discriminative for all
different types of faces okay that's the
point that I'm trying to make maybe I
should have started from this this
models turn yeah language I can do the
same thing
we're not using engineering features not
engineered features no no no if I were
using engineered features that's another
reason people tell me there is nothing
surprising there you're using sift
features that of course they're generic
no I'm not using sift features that's
the whole point that's what I'm trying
to say is that I train it for a binary
classifier that learns the equivalent of
sift features we haven't tried with
engineered features no much time do I
have here okay okay all right good so
let me kind of move on real quick here
okay so this idea of like I don't know
how to call this effects like I've been
using unwanted learning for this but
like it's not unwanted unintended I
don't know if you have a good adjective
you know and end up using it like I'll
give you a know ten bucks
so okay what was I gonna say okay so it
manifests itself in all sorts of other
ways so so far I've been talking about
kind of this unintentional leakage and
things that are eyes and intentionally
of course you can do the same thing you
can exploit this to artificially
introduce things into the model so there
is this thing that I actually like a lot
but apparently no but it does with like
backdoor attacks where you can sort of
introduce a backdoor into the image so
that when I wear these glasses I get
missed recognized as someone else and
again this works much better than just
data poisoning because you sort of
without having any impact on the actors
on the main tasks you can introduce
additional tasks in the model and the
model still does them well this matters
in federated learning where the models
are assembled from multiple models and
stuff like this and this is actually
very hard to detect so this is this is
kind of another angle on this is that
you can't tell by looking at a model
what tasks it's performing okay maybe
that's kind of an obvious point but even
if you know what task it was trained
it's very hard to tell by looking at the
model that doesn't actually also like
perform all sorts of other tasks or that
it didn't learn also all sorts of like
other things this leakage else I'll skip
that this leakage from internal
representations is a problem when you
get like white box visibility into the
model because if you like for example
again and federated learning and
distributed learning scenarios you don't
get to see the final model you see like
snapshots of the model over time and
what you see even in that setting is
that in the top layers of the model you
see these features that are relevant to
the task you train the model for in the
lower layers what you see is all kinds
of like unintended features that leak
information about training data like you
can see if this picture is too small but
this is a model that was trained to like
separate triangles and squares well but
here it learned to separate by color in
the lower layers which is another
example of performing and uncorrelated
task that's unconnected well unconnected
is not right
I'm correlated with the final task and
yet here the model is clearly learning
to do this alright so what am I trying
to say with all of this so remember I
started by saying that when people look
at models today they ask if the model
learned its task well typically measured
by test occurs so what I'll be trying to
say is that this doesn't answer the
question of what else did the model
learn so because in addition to the task
you gave it
it could have implicitly or explicitly
intentionally or accidentally learn all
kinds of things that are not captured by
its main task
it could have memorized its training
data and leaked it it could have
discovered features that are
uncorrelated to the task
that you gave it and by the way you're
right that uncorrelated doesn't mean not
useful however statistically correlated
it could actually learn privacy
violating tasks like you know you train
for a generic purpose but I'd learned to
recognize people's I did it is
authorship of texts and stuff like this
or it could even be abused to kind of
incorporate some backdoor functionality
incorporate an artificial task that
somebody put in there to cause it
misbehave in certain ways and none of
these things are captured by measuring
the models test accuracy so if all you
look at is test accuracy and test train
gap and any conventional metrics of
model quality none of them like these
effects of unwanted unintended learning
they do not manifest there so if we want
to understand what models are really
learning what they're really discovering
about the data and about us and stuff
like this then we need to take like a
deeper look at this and we need metrics
for that that conventional ways of doing
it aren't gonna do it all right so let
me stop here
[Music]
all questions and let the discuss I just
have it Oh
oh yeah there is a dedicated
embarrassing right did you go in and say
we're going to learning other things
besides oh oh by taking guesses okay
okay so how do we know what to look for
yeah bye bye yes by taking guesses I
mean it came out of like like originally
were not as this in the context of this
federated learning but that's a little
different because in federated learning
you're gonna get this it's kind of hard
to explain without going into technical
details you kind of get like updates to
the model based on small like batches of
data and there were observe that this
updates leak and leak information that
is like because but updates are directly
based on the data so it's not very
surprising and then we asked our self
questions what if we take a trained
model and all these things that are
leaked by updates maybe they leak by the
final model and that can informed our
search but in terms of coming up with
tasks to test for this is just you know
things that look plausible and that I
could arguably sell as privacy violating
so sorry I'm not like procedurally what
happens now okay do I sit down all right
thank you can you hear me yeah all right
so I guess somebody's bad news is
somebody else's good news right so every
time that vitaly speaks i guess i feel
that whatever we as theoreticians
conjecture could be wrong he actually
finds a way to show that it's going
wrong great and it's a way for us to
convince people that so another way I
can thought that this would be a good
news so when we talk about synthetic
data so what bothers me a lot is well so
suppose we think of some users of the
synthetic data and we say well okay
let's generate in such a way that it's
useful for this thing but why would it
be useful for other tasks so if indeed
there is a formal way to say that this
tasks are somehow correlated right so
that would be useful but it asks if
while right so to sort one thing it's
possible policies so it is very
interesting that kind of Vitaly is
uncovering the snails that somehow many
useful tasks could be correlated in some
extrinsic way so there's one point so
another
I think so of course is there's a shame
I want to ask so how can we model it
formally so what's going on here and
maybe in particular so some of the
things are here on the slide can they be
ruled out if we use private algorithms
so if we use the creation
so the models are eventually private in
some way but of course we think in many
cases about differential privacy of the
outputs but there is something else
going on here so there's some internal
state so how do we ensure maybe we
should try and should be trying to
ensure that some internal state is also
differentially private and we have
models let's say for vocal algorithms
right so but maybe there's something in
between there so the model that's
getting trained continuously maybe after
every stage its internal state should be
differentially private so is there
something interesting going on there can
we model it this is the model going to
have strictly less power because it's
differentially private or not so another
thing is so okay but Ali says I guess
this is if we this at so but we cannot
train for certain features without
training water features can we actually
formally prove that there is no way to
train it it's not that this methods
don't work but can we actually prove
that there are features which you can
train for those features you also have
to Train part
well another thing is actually testing
or learning for privacy order and
attribute so there's a possible option
to test that the program is doing in
order is doing what it's private or
maybe it's preserving some other things
[Applause]
these are good questions by the way no
no I this is it I mean this is I think
these are excellent questions because
unsurprising as it is this idea that you
cannot learn a without B or that the
only way to learn a is by discovering a
bunch of generic concepts that actually
enable all kinds of learning I feel it's
a very powerful idea and even though
people like react to it like what's
surprising here I've never seen it even
like explained clearly anywhere yes
people are only looking at whatever the
motherland is this specific path the
kind of face recognition is the perfect
example right so how do people like
train based on admission models they
train them kind of recognize particular
individuals in the training set and then
like low and behold when you kind of
take the embedding layer that it can do
in the wild face recognition mmm so it's
not and you know no one says okay we
just want we just care about whether
they recognize the celebrities that we
trained on it obvious that the eventual
goal is different yeah well I mean but
you're talking about like in this
example that's just generalization so
you want the model to generalize now
she's saying that the the embedding like
if you sort of shave off the last layer
or two on the network you can retrain
the last layer or whatever that's right
- that's treinta that's transfer that's
transfer learning when you retrain I
mean you you get that last embedding
layer no retraining but you're changing
then I smell transfer part of the
network using a different classifier on
top of that sticking a different
difference that like the original
moments at different times for largest
this you're right I mean I think ok now
I think I hear what you're saying you're
saying that the representations that are
learned are more general than what then
that asked that you gave yes I guess
that's what I'm saying
what's amazing to me is how much more
general
sure III don't know what's the procedure
okay now refuge wanna wrap my head
around this isn't specifically that
let's say you trying to recognize faces
and then you learn that the images have
eyes noses and a mouth that's not
surprising maybe but if you all you want
to know does this image have an eye in
it and then somewhere in the model or
somewhere in this learning to recognize
I don't quite know how to distinguish it
okay because if you think about this
maybe there is no difference maybe to
learn to recognize that there is an eye
in the face you need to know this is a
face you need to segment it you need to
find the features that segment the face
into eyes nose and mouth and perform all
the processing just to recognize that
there is an eye
once you've performed all that
processing you're doing full-on facial
analysis meaning that yes you're gonna
have yourself a facial recognition model
because you will have to extract the
same features that a facial recognition
model is extracting just to do a thing
as simple as determining if there is an
island so but the surprising thing to me
is actually it's again goes back to you
know what good news little I asked right
which is there are maybe no simple tasks
here is that the only way to do even
simple tasks is to do exactly well not
exactly but to extract general
representations that are useful for all
sorts of tasks that there are no
shortcuts here that's that's one maybe
somewhat surprising part which is maybe
a little bit more surprising that when I
do facial recognition for a particular
group of people it has to extract facial
features that turn out to be useful for
recognizing even other people well I'm
not saying I'm not even doing facial
recognition I'm doing something much you
know
coarser grained and yet it still
discovers features that are useful for
facial recognition degrading real-world
performance but actually it's sort of
weird we're saying it's like that you
can kind of think of this as like
profound overfitting that then makes
what the model has learned actually much
more general I don't think overfeeding
is I mean first of all I don't know what
is the technical definition of
overfitting okay so but but it's hard
for me to think of this as overfitting
because it's not what this is learning I
mean as in like like let me come back to
this example that now I'm think I should
use more often how it learns to
recognize the feature that is not
represented on the training data set
that's the opposite of overfitting that
that feature is not even in there so how
do you mean like how do i over feed by
learning directly there is something
that is not on the training data set
this is just showing kind of like how
general the learning is that the things
that it extracts I useful for things
well beyond what it's this is anti
overfitting in some sense the process of
trying to generalize well there's one
particular task it's sort of like
discovering a bunch of stuff that is
actually maybe not particularly like
necessary strictly necessary for that
task which you know I can think of as
being like weirdly same like it's gonna
learn all the stuff we're just like
peculiar to this training set but
somehow still like does it really affect
the ability to this ultimate model to
termites well we've respects that text
and other stuff that learned isn't the
end up being useful for with it with
other with respect of all their tasks
yeah so now I'm thinking like remember I
complained how I don't have a good term
for this maybe overlearning is actually
is actually a good good description of
what's going on whoa there are like
let's let's go left to right that's not
okay my life sorry these examples how
many parameters of these models are
there compared to like what is the I'm
looking for right so like the size of a
learned models yes good good good good
good good good good good so this is this
is a long conversation I can have about
this I won't bore everyone so yes so
like if you really over parameterize the
models you can like this phenomenon is
like amazing
right it's basic it's much worse than
over parameterize models because over
parameterize models it's gonna do it
it's gonna learn all kinds of things all
kinds of representations it is over
parameterize ation like like like this
experiments work much more beautifully
with over parameterize models of course
that's a little bit stacking the deck in
our favor so when we do the experiments
we try to kind of take the model like
from the literature which is like that
is maybe still over parameterize but not
artificial over parameterize but I can
make everything here much worse by like
dumping like two more layers on top of
it and making it like year wide okay I
have a very hard time imagining a linear
separator that was that was trained to
learn gender is going to do the same but
the linear separator is gonna suck up at
recognizing gender but but again let me
come back to you know good news potala
here this is very deep it's like maybe
written what
it's it's because you actually were come
in here when that joke was made so so
but like this thing like maybe learning
gender like real and learning gender
requires actually I like learning
everything you can about the face so
that's there is some deep meaning in
that statement
no maybe I should that does actually a
good point all right let's let's move on
yeah sorry I know you've been oh sorry
sorry it's another way of looking at it
is to say maybe all this data that
you're looking at is really in a very
low dimensional subspace so those
features that the CN n picks up on it's
pretty much the same whether it's your
face of my face of Brad Pitt's face oh
and they were no other people in livings
so maybe that's all it is and if you add
a little bit of noise to all these
features to make it private you would
possibly lose I'm adding two questions
here so possibly lose all utility in
that yeah yeah I don't know this kind of
goes to the deep question of what is it
that these models are really picking on
okay and it takes somebody who knows you
know much more amel than I do - that's
right I'm not this is I'm not the right
person to even like start answering that
question but I kind of I I think it's a
very meaningful question to ask it looks
like this may have some implications
also for the consequences of limiting
information set limits they will learn
[Applause]
as an example and then maybe we are but
I assure you going with this but what
about this what if you can't what if
this things that you want to learn
common bundles what if there is no way
of learning what you really want to
learn like how is data limitation gonna
help
listening to you and they I'm hearing
regulators say for instance we want for
cybersecurity purposes we really need to
collect all the data because we need to
detect you know cyberattacks and we use
machine learning for that but we are we
care about your privacy so we are going
to ensure that some of the data is not
going to be available but there is a
cost for that right it certainly can't
really oh I said something yeah hi I
don't know I mean what this means for
regulating this things and like laser
can't set limits and you know or that
there is a cost that is associated with
setting limits if you there is some sort
of learning that you cannot is it a way
to actually measure well uh yeah I don't
know how to answer that other than you
know as far as I can tell there isn't
even a way to measure everything that's
learned so it would be strange of their
work today a way to measure everything
that's lost okay so like I guess
initially set simple you then admitted
there oh they simple in terms of the
objective function yeah the but I'm
wondering so for example if I wanted to
train a model to recognize people with
glasses right whether or not we would be
able to that's that's one of our
examples
you well but if you limited prohibited
it from learning some set of things for
example about protected that is one of
our examples is the is exactly like
that's like this example learning if
somebody wears glasses like that binary
classifiers actually one of our like
most prominent examples the performance
goes down steeply so I guess I you know
another maybe another models are sloppy
right I do think this is about over
learning and so and wondering is it is
this that we can't do it because I so
let me give you kind of an intuition for
what I think is happening what does it
mean to learn that somebody wears
glasses I mean look around here losses
come in all shapes and forms and so on
to get really high accuracy what he
really need to do is to segment the face
first of all like fine this is the face
this is where the eyes are on the face
this is the eye this is something around
the eye so you need actually to perform
to get like real hackers and the task
pretty fine grained analysis of the area
around the eyes
turns out these features enable pretty
accurate trace detection and they even
enable reasonable accurate gender
detection and when I describe it like
this maybe it's not surprising at all
that to get high accuracy on glass
detection you're gonna get yourself a
race classifier just out of that but the
sensor in question that is exactly what
people in censoring ask I don't think
it's not possible I think that
empirically existing techniques that we
quantitatively evaluated for censoring
models to prevent them from learning
destroy their the performance of the
glass classifier this is a purely
empirical statement about existing
techniques for censoring and we did some
survey of the literature implemented
this techniques that's it
because they'd be Justin to me that like
race and gender my guess is those things
are so intricately organized that you
couldn't do it but with glasses I want
to say maybe you could existing
techniques fail
that's all maybe just maybe in some way
what George was asking is is there a way
to technically formalize an objective
that is don't or in the following I
think that's that's a reasonable
technical point and there is a way I
mean like if you look at censoring
literature they do have various
objectives about like that dispersed in
terms of like mutual information between
representations and so on these are very
reasonable objectives all I can tell you
today is that the techniques that people
have proposed for achieving these
objectives they achieve these objectives
and the performance of for the main task
goes down that's Haitian of the entire
process oh like messing up your
representations I haven't even thought
about this connection have a simple
question and then a comment okay so just
on this whole exchange about the glasses
and the race of the defense and of
gender it's the same true about the
shape and the colour because I think
that was actually the most surprising of
all the examples so that's the simple
question and the comment is that after
all this discussion maybe that suggests
that the way that we have to interpret
something like the GDP our purpose
restriction is it it has to be about the
use the purposes in which to which you
actually use the thing because of how
difficult it is to disentangle whether
in principle or in practice to
disentangle learning the thing you care
about learning right and the things you
might like so it's sort of I think
guides us to we can only interpret such
restrictions in the how we actually use
the box I
like I don't know why you'd answer the
question about the shapes sorry sorry
what is the question like why you what
highway why are we learning color when
we're learning shapes and for better one
I don't know if it's not okay I don't
know if it's no no no III don't think in
that case it's necessary like that
particular thing was in a somewhat
different part of the talk is just
showing that it extracted low-level
features that also separate by color
like that could be easily sensible i I
wasn't making a statement that that was
uncensored I'm just making that just if
you just do morning without worrying
about censoring it's going to extract
all kinds of like low-level features so
love it whereas like the classes in the
race like you were saying has everything
to do I mean they extract like features
all kinds of yeah so so but I'm not
saying that that's luck and that part is
not inherent and by the way like this
thing after I explained that like why
these are related everybody's like yeah
of course the losses are related though
it wasn't obvious to me maybe it's
almost of smarter people but but so on
this thing about purpose look I I mean
there are people here who are experts on
exactly that kind of thing I'm not but
it is true that yes like it's one thing
about regulating use but it's very hard
to regulate it's gonna be very hard to
regulate if somebody were to try what is
actual alert okay but I do feel that we
will have this problem is that like
somebody is gonna take a model for
credit scoring or something that matters
to people I know health insurance or
something and gonna look at it okay some
enterprising journalist is going to look
at and say look it's actually doing
different things yeah
scores for like like studying car
insurance prices and like a bunch of
other stuff and like the theory is that
there's like something that's been
learned here that's like more general
than the specific task so and like
people don't become unhappy at that like
that's the problem that's the problem
that that like it's it's no longer going
to be about regulating use it's going to
be about regulating actual decision
making and here you have a model that's
kind of doing decision-making that is
treating different people differently
and there's going to be like journalists
and state legislators I mean they know
delivered a lot of unless about Imelda
Naidu and
they're going to be passing the laws
that have no technical meaning like
that's that's the risk here
[Applause]